hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in rhetoric book 2 aristotle analyzes at
considerable length
anger and its opposite calmness or
mildness and in the course of discussing
mildness which is the opposite of anger
he
looks at a number of important dynamics
and one of those that's particularly
interesting and applicable although
perhaps aristotle is generalizing a
little bit too much with this
has to do with being angry at one person
but discharging your anger at another
person or at least another
target and then becoming calm
with respect to the first person
becoming no longer
angry
with them no longer feeling it no longer
directing your anger
at them and he talks about this at first
in in a very general way he says that
vengeance or whatever we want to
translate it is
retribution revenge timuria right and
this is interesting because usually he
uses tim races is what we're aiming for
but this is the closely connected term
a restoration of
honor respect social status
self-esteem however we want to put it
setting things right so vengeance
that is quite literally in the greek
taken it's coming from the
word uh the verb
to grab to seize to take right vengeance
that's taken
against another person par alu right
literally against uh the other
calms he says prague
anger that you feel against
a person heteron another person
and then he says something really
remarkable
even if the anger that you feel
against this person is greater
than the anger that you feel against the
person who you
do in fact take some sort of retribution
against so what this implies
is that anger can be
redirected
against targets that
are closer or easier to access or more
convenient
there could be a matter of chance as
well and so there's only so much
anger available you could say if we're
following out this idea
and he brings up two examples
each of which helps us to see
an important aspect
or
side of this dynamic so the first one
that he brings up is this guy philo
crates
and this is a very interesting
case right it shows us that if we can
delay
other people
possibly getting angry with us over
something until they've got a better
target
then maybe we can keep them from getting
angry with us we can keep them in a calm
state so it says uh philocrates when
somebody asked him
why he did not
justify
himself and it's it's literally here in
the greek
apollo right an apology it's interesting
because that's the word that we get
apology
from right
and in ancient greek
apologene did not mean to
say you're sorry and make amends it
meant to give a defense speech
typically within the courts so you know
for example plato's apology and
xenophon's apology are both socrates
justifying his own actions at his
trial so
this isn't yet at a trial
and so this shows us that the scope for
justifying yourself could be you know
much more
uh extensive socially and they're asking
why don't you justify yourself people
are getting miffed with you but you know
you could say something to them
and he says
something quite interesting instead of
saying why
he says something about time he says not
yet
why not yet why not justify yourself
right away
so that you can get the matter dealt
with well he realizes if he tries to
justify himself right away then he
becomes a target people are going to get
angry with him and so he says
i'll justify
myself i'll bring myself to people's
attention
when i see
somebody else
who is accused and the word for that is
dia
uh beblemon right and so it's it's a
you could say accused slandered
brought up as a bad person right
again publicly not necessarily in the
law courts but i'll do it when i see
somebody else who is accused of what of
the same thing
alone idiot idiot
is uh idiot
you know
the same kind of matter and so
why would he do that because he realizes
something that aristotle's pointing out
if people
see somebody else being accused of the
same thing and their attention turns to
that person and now they're angry at
that person
i can bring up the fact that i did it
after they discharged their anger onto
that person
and they won't be as angry with me or
perhaps they'll be completely calm
they'll be like well
you know
you're right it's it's good that you ju
that you you know
acknowledge the fact that you did this
thing over here but we've already taken
care of matters over here now
is this rational not really but
aristotle is noting something that does
happen
in human psychology it's almost as if
anger
because it is as he'll say in another
place in the nick of mccain ethics a
hasty servant it wants to get his job
done
right away
he's got another interesting example as
well where it's more a matter of luck or
chance
um ergo felis the athenian people
are
angry with him by the way i should
mention with phil philocrates the people
the deimos right are the ones who are
angry so the athenians are angrier with
him than with calisthenics
and so you could expect that ergophilus
is going to
get a worse
sentence a worse treatment right and
interestingly the word that's being used
for
angry there is halepinontes
[Music]
creating difficulty uh being you know
indignant is one way in which it's
translated here
they're angry enough however or
indignant enough to condemned
calisthenics
to death
and so
they do that the day before
aragophilus is coming up before them
and because they've already condemned
him to death calisthenics the previous
day
they acquit erego phyllis
why
well because
they have you know as aristotle is going
to say
they've discharged their anger at
another person the greek for that is ace
alone
and this is quite interesting because we
could we can use the word discharged
with this metaphor like anger is
something in a container and you pour it
out onto somebody else and now the anger
is gone but the greek term there on a
low so scene is actually
something along the lines of having like
spent money right having exhausted
resources so you've you've gone through
the anger that you're feeling and
because
you've used up that anger
now you're in a state of calmness even
towards
somebody who previously
you were angry with or could get angry
with right and so both of these examples
are really quite apt because they
show this dynamic that aristotle is keen
to bring to our attention that anger
against
one person
might in fact be appeased or lessened or
calmed by discharging that anger
at another person even if
you're angrier at the first person then
you are at the second person and we
should remember that the rhetoric is
primarily about how you can
arouse or calm or get rid of particular
emotions so that you can attain
certain results and you know we could
think of this in very cynical ways we
could also think about this in ways that
protect those who we care about this is
a very important dynamic to note
you